muchos se preguntaron cómo es posible
que el jefe de Los mercenarios de Wagner
se atreviese a marchar con su columna de
hombres armados rumbo a Moscú el diario
New York Times cree que tiene la
respuesta y resulta que prigó sin tenía
apoyos importantes dentro de la cúpula
militar entre ellos un general muy
conocido sergei quien conocido como El
carnicero de Siria tanto prigo sin como
surobikin se conocen de aquellos años
ambos lucharon juntos en Siria el Kelvin
no ha tardado en contestar a esta
información ha dicho que hay demasiados
chismes y especulaciones en torno a la
intentona ya sofocada de el pasado
sábado pero hay algunos datos que
apuntan a que había más gente en el
entorno de la cúpula militar rusa que
estaban dispuestos a hacer algún
movimiento de fuerza para lograr la
destitución de el ministro de defensa
sergei
que se desmarcó desde el principio de
esta intentona de esta sublevación
Armada sigue el supuesto trabajando para
el Estado Mayor de la defensa ru